up next we got Dave from Ontario Canada
I want to go to Ontario - hey Theo
Brennan this is Dave from Ontario was it
whispering and I got a debate questions
not Brendon at least he's in the gym by
the snack machine rock stars or rappers
let me know what you think Gang Gang
buzz buzz buzz young man by the snack
machine at the gym I feel I hope to hang
out there too sometimes I'd see you dude
yeah reload that sugar levels um you're
over your shoulder pressing these nerd
ropes rock stars or rappers as far as
who gets more hoes dude if it was the
90s rock stars 80s rock stars all day
dude think about the rock stars back in
the day okay so I think you have to talk
about rock stars at that time they don't
have rock stars that's what I'm saying
there's no rock stars Nickelback doesn't
count
well Nickelback also was a 20 year ago
reference I mean let's talk about a
recent rock star who's a new hearing
harder Nick Carter yeah core of the
Carter three little Wayne is almost a
rock star now when you think about it
he's played more guitar than half the
[ __ ] other you know guys who had even
went on tour blink when they do right
any any left and you know what the
scouts to life oh really
did you not think about this before you
jumped in with blink-182
all the small things where the [ __ ] is
happening right now
he's like I like to skate but not this
much what a skate till they start
playing the music everybody well escape
do you start doing some skater [ __ ] the
tight jeans don't make you a skater
little Wayne man yes can you think of a
rock who's a rut the biggest rock star
right now who's the redhead with the
with the with the fucked-up eyes yeah ed
Sheeran probably the biggest rock star
you got yeah ed Sheeran he's a rock star
well he's Jim you know music well Get
Well name a rock star
he's mall rock just just like named
stone who's not pop John Mayer
maybe America it well no Smith was hot
in the 60s 70s 80s 90s I know well no
you breed Jared Leto thirty Seconds to
Mars thirty Seconds to Mars six degrees
is Saturn or whatever yeah Mars what are
you saying you say post below but I was
like hey that's a rapper really these
rapper pop but post Malone's kind of
fair cuz he does do a little bit of it
dude yeah whenever yeah when we was
children they had on to Led Zeppelin
ac/dc yeah smash journey bruh journey
[ __ ] died on the journey the whole
pan bro dude lead singer Korean now how
about beef and Tony broke day I remember
these have a magazine that kid would
come to you once a month and it was like
pictures of the ride and they've been
fighting each other with [ __ ] broken
bottles dude Rock of Love I went and saw
no Yahoo's thirdly whose rep Michael oh
dude Brett who Goo Dolls
oh now then now we're talking you know
you lose jobs around me you know you
look similarly you know I'm a [ __ ]
nine of their shows dude I follow him
across I followed them one time I
followed them across about one-eighth
the Pennsylvania dude I'm a Dave slave I
will [ __ ] follow Dave Matthews to the
end of Earth satellite you're dating
yourself bro Dave Matthews you like the
Goo Goo Dolls Dave Matthews you have the
same stylist take Matthew Davis appeared
bro where's that [ __ ] dude [ __ ] dude
he's selling out all over bro new album
bro did he where's the Goo Goo Dolls Goo
Goo Dolls are everywhere they're
performing somewhere yeah they are so so
State Matthews hmm yeah hater yeah yeah
I am but think about how big rock stars
we're back in the day there's nothing
bigger
there's nothing dude Metallica they're
still doing it yeah now it's a lungful
yeah but whatever so I think Rob but
then rappers get more like I think I
don't know rappers see me they get more
like those video vixens yeah nothing
better I don't know and they get those
IG hoes - yeah
then big booty [ __ ] they sliding
those Dee
and whatever city they're into Jesus
Christ yeah man I booked this day it's
just it's a time thing you know you're
talking about the 70s 80s rock stars
destroyed what do you guys think let's
get some culture that's a rappers just
because rappers get all color chicks
black girls would never like [ __ ]
they were only [ __ ] white girls you
know what I mean black girls were only
[ __ ] white girls no Metallica was
like only [ __ ] white girls and ac/dc
like they're all white girls right they
didn't have yeah they didn't have black
girls coming to their audience right rap
is one of the few genres where if all
cultures will go watch the music yes
everyone everyone goes to watch it I
would say rappers yeah
rappers they cover all demos everyone
pops azam what was the guy's question
originally specifically what was he
saying gets more rappers or look it's
worth ladies kind of an outdated
question cuz there's no rock stars two
homeboys point post Malone's kind of the
closest yeah you know it's so tall it's
tough to figure that out man it's very
tough it's tough to figure that out I
don't know for the people I ask no I
mean you're a big Goo Goo Dolls fan I'm
a fast yes I think that says it all but
I'd say rappers if I had to go it's a
John Mayer though is the closest thing
that we have and I think he's obviously
he's been with every woman in the whole
world so he's probably so many people's
dad I cannot think of one rock star chin
you're in the music business
yeah chin [ __ ] [ __ ] no dude dude
I'm gonna take some of your hair out of
your head
do ya welcome to the new Korea dude for
every time you don't [ __ ] have an
answer we take a piece of hair out of
your head you know Travis Barker is kind
of the most rock guy he's right who
Corey Taylor for the Titans no that's
Corey Davis who is it
Oh Slipknot do you still have a lot of
those oh I see Jamie Jost he still have
a lot of those skunk metal bands you
know ICP ink-stained Clown Posse you got
a limp Biskit Fred Durst Fred Durst
busting nuts no in his bedroom alone
Fred Durst on his bedroom alone he's not
you
doing albums whatever dude I don't want
to talk about it anymore yeah I don't
it's hard to figure out I think good
call though with insane clown posse I
yeah I don't know I don't know green day
green day go away Coldplay how they call
play yeah you got guys let me be like
James Blake I mean he's a he but he's I
mean it's just it's tough it's like what
is a rock star now it doesn't exist the
rule 5 Adam Levine he's a rock star he's
a rock star I think he can play an
instrument maybe that's the qualifier
fan of Adam Levine I'm a fan of maroon 5
you are oh yeah he's beautiful Adam
Levine I saw him in Halloween party but
I'm straight
so I'm you went as a straight man you
saw yeah
I've went my whole life as a straight
man dude Wow take the mascot real face
dude get me out of this question they're
59% rock stars wow that didn't make
sense back then it's like we need a time
period that's true
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]